それから質問のセクションに入ります
この質問は私に送られたもので
で 私の文章ではありません
世間の中を知るってどういうことですか？あ
世の中を知る 世の中にはいろいろなルール
しきたり 常識 これなんでしたっけ？え？ん？暗黙の了解などがあり
その場にそぐわない行動言動をすると
なんだこいつはという白い目で見られます
ここで私の答えかな 悪
違法 迷信に関わるものなら頑固と断ることですよと
別にこちらでルールなんかあったあってもね
なんだこいつはと思われたってもいいんじゃないですか
やってることは悪であって
違法であって 迷信だったら頑固で断るんですよ
他は身につく努力する
世間のルール ルール しきたり
そういうものを身につく努力はするんですよ
してください しかし それが悪だったら
違法だったらいい加減やめてほしい
だから適切に社会に合わせればいいんです
完全に合わせなくてもいいんです
これ続きやります 質問 one の続き
その場その場の空気は相対的なもので
どんな場合でも通用する正しいやり方などないので
知恵がないと頭が回転しないと世の中についていけないんですという質問です
だからルールにしたっても
その場その場でしきたりといったっても
ちょっと本来きたらいろいろありますからね
これがよっぽど頭が良くなければできないんだという質問です
答えはね ブッダが説く十悪を徹底的にやめることに励むと解決します
世の中のしきたり ルールはどうであろうと気にすることがないんですよ
お釈迦様が十悪教えてますよ
それだけやめてもらえば
もう世界の人間言うことはね
全然もう関係なくなっちゃうんです
だから この複雑な世の中でうまく正しく生きるためには
我々はあの人の言葉 この人の言葉と聞いちゃうと
もう生きていられないんです
みんな智慧がないでしょうし
真理が知らないでしょうに
世間のこと知らないでしょ
だからもちろん人の話聞いても聞いてもただ疲れるだけ
ですから お釈迦様がおっしゃった十悪
殺生するなかれ 盗むなかれという
それ守っちゃえば完璧にうまくいくんですよ
で 十善を行うように努める
それで結構楽なんですけど
また 質問 one は終わってないんです
本人がさらさらと書いてますから
私は間にちょっと愚痴を挟んだだけ
無邪気な子供が大人になるにつれて
いろいろなことを身に吸い付けていき
やがて社会人と呼ばれるようになる
お釈迦様は 人間が世の中に出ていくことについて
どのように説かれているのでしょうか
どのように世の中を知っていけば良いのでしょうか？という
一応質問の内容は皆様にはよく理解できると思います
これは皆様の社会環境から作られた質問です
で 答え 人間は悪の感情で生きていて
罪を犯す 他人に迷惑をかける
結果として不幸になる
社会構成と時代に関係のない
普遍的に 悪だと罪だと言われるものを知ることです
だから 子供から大人になるまでは何を勉強すればいいかって
何を身につけばいいかという質問でしょうね
だったら普遍的な悪がありますよと
社会と関係ない 時代と関係ない
悪があるんです それだけ勉強すればすごい簡単ですからね
感情も普遍的なもので
それは何かと理解する
それから人間の感情は普遍的ですよね
子供は何を勉強するべきかというと
この感情を勉強するんですよ
それで人生勉強になりますよ
私の感情も人の感情もほぼ同じだから
感情は だから人間学とか人間論とか
そんな哲学とか 何の意味もないんです
もうこんなのやってもやってもキリがないんです
知識ですから だからずっと把握するためには
人間の感情だけを勉強する
それから罪は聖書で書いてある罪やら
イランのコーランで書いてある罪やら
ヒンドゥー教で書いてある罪
そんなのはどうでもいいんだけど
普遍的な罪だけ勉強しておけ
自分の悪感情を知れば世間を知ってるのですよ
自分が持ってる悪い感情
悪になる感情 殺したいとかね
嫌な気持ちとか 怒りとか憎しみとか
それをよく知っておけば
もう世間知ってますよ
で これが答えなんです
問題はこのスライドに全て長い文章だから入りきれません
入ったら文字が小さくて読めないので
まあそういう切るはめになっちゃったんです
それで質問外に 世間知らずの危険性
1 今の世の中 人を騙してお金を巻き上げようとしたり
人を操って自分の利益のために利用しようとしたり
悪い人やずるい人がたくさんいます
例えば そういう中で無防備に人を信用して言われるままに動いてしまうような人
これ豆腐問題でしょ これは一つの世間知らずでした
質問の続き 自分の中にはそういうずるいずるずるさがないから気づかないので
ある意味善人なのかもしれませんが
悪人の食い物になってしまうのもバカな話です
悪人に捕まらないために賢くなるには何が必要ですか
答え 甘い話に乗らないこと
世間のこと 人のことを知らなくても
これちょっと間違いなんですけど
甘い話に乗らない方がいいんですよ
自分が世間のことをあまり知らない
無知でいいんですよ あまり人間のことも知らない
それでもいいんです 自分が百姓だけ
もう田んぼを作ってるだけで全然知らないんだから
人間のことは それでもいいんですよ
生きることは楽であるべき
でしょ たとえ白鳥さんであろうとも
生きることは楽じゃないでしょうに
そんなにすごい頭がなくてもそれぐらいわかるでしょうに
なんでそれ忘れる？よっぽど無地でしょう
この田舎から東京に来るでしょうに
来たらもう地獄に落ちたようにもう最悪
うまくいかない だから人生っていうのは大変苦しいもんだというのを事実ですから
それ知っておけば簡単には儲かることはできません
自分で努力しないなら豊かにはなりませんということを覚えておきましょう
お金がお金が降ってこないんだよと
それぐらいは理解しておかないと
人間失格では ありませんかということ
これ人間失格ですよ もう詐欺師に騙されたということは
だって甘い話に乗った時点でもう生きることは大変なのに
これ忘れちゃいますよ
それはすごいとんでもない話で
人間失格と私は言いたいんです
騙されたら騙された側ではなくて
答え続きます 騙されたと思うなら善人ではありません
あの人は善人かもしれませんと書いてあったんですけど
騙されたと思ったらもう善人じゃありませんだからね
悔しがってますからね
バカなんですよ 人間失格なんですよ
この人は詐欺師だ 嘘を言っているのだ
しかし 何かをあげないと帰れないほどしつこい奴だと思ってあげることは自己防衛です
例えばしつこい人が来て
喋るを喋る もう詐欺師だとよく知ってますよ
自分も でもなかなか追い出せませんし
帰って帰ってと言っても帰らないし
この宗教とか信仰 なんとか党とかね
来るでしょう もう聖書の一部持ってきてなかなか出ていかないんですよ
だから自分もあまり宗教を知らないで
もう判断もできないんだったら
よくわかりました もう資料全部ちょうだいと
勉強して連絡しますからと言って
電話番号でも書いてもらって帰っちゃえばそれでいいでしょうに
別に騙されたわけないです
それは自己防衛なんです
私なら逆な方法 まあ結構もうもうもうぐちゃぐちゃ喋りますからね
教えに何かもうくだらないものを持ってきたら
要りませんと言わない
どうぞ説明してください
ビシビシ説明してもらうんです
それからきめ細かく質問するんです
それで本人に言わせるんですよ
これがやっぱりこれぐらいのものだったらね
これぐらい値段っていうのは役に立たんでしょうねとかね
本人も言うんですよ まあやっぱりこれぐらいのことしかできません
だからビシビシ聞くんだから
何が役に立つこと じゃあこれこれ
これぐらいですね またありますか？いえ
これぐらいで と  これぐらいことだったら
これぐらいお金っていうのはどうでしょうかねと
それだったらね ちょっとと本人言うんだからね
もう全部もう畳んで帰るしかないんですよ
宗教の場合は私はまあよく勉強しますから
どうぞどうぞと で もうとことん聞いて
まあこれだったらどうします？これだったらどうします？あれだったらどうします？どうせ知識がないんだから
あの 何か本持ってきて
それ読み上げるしか能力ないんだから
知ってます 言うともう返事も何もできなくなっちゃって
もう向こうは遠慮して帰るんです
その場合 一応 3時間  2時間ぐらいまだ
止まってもらいます 宗教の場合はなぜかというと
そうするともう疲れ果てて隣の家に行けません
隣の人まで助けてあげるんです
そこからがおそらくもう 2 3ヶ月間は出ないと思います
で 皆様にはそこまではね
まあできないんだから
できる方がやってみてもいいんだけど
ちょっとかなり頭が動かないと
ちょっと危険なところもありますから
まあ適当に自己防衛すればいいんです
詐欺師でも困っているに違いない
少々協力しますと思うことは善行為です
相手は詐欺師ですから
まあ詐欺師でも困っているでしょう
まあとにかくもう生きるためにやっていることだから
まあいいや いくらかあげますと
いうふうにあげることが善行為ですよ
それは別に それだけ良い人なんです
助けてあげようと だから宗教の宣伝に来る人々に
私はお茶とかお菓子とか
そういうのを全部一生懸命あげます
で 答えが次 悪人に捕まりたくないと思うなら
悪人に限って言ってることは嘘なので
この悪人が言うことは嘘でしょ
事実を言わないんだから
すぐバレますよ 論理が成り立っていないはずですよ
矛盾ばかり垂れしてるはずなんです
なんでそれ発見しないんですかね
なんで話に乗るんですかね
人間失格ですよ 相手が詐欺師で悪人だったら
科学的なデータやら研究のデータやら
そんな言えるはずがないでしょうに
そんなものを持ってきたっても
すぐ嘘やとバレるでしょう
それを面白おかしく言って笑えば
物の見事に逃げていくのですよ
だから別によ その人を批判する必要もなくて
そちら様はこう言うんだけど
なんかここら辺ちょっとおかしいんじゃないのと言って
本人は批判しないで やっぱりこういう文章を書いた人っていうのはね
結構もうおかしいね おかしいねとかね
笑えますねとかね 一つの一つのポイントに二人で笑っちゃえばね
向こうは全部畳んで何のことなくできますよ
そんなに問題はありません
脅かされ 脅されることは全然気にしないこと
時々脅すんですよ あんた地獄に落ちますから
これ信仰しなくちゃとかね
そんなに別に気にしなくていいんですよ
これ脅しでしょうとかね
はい それは宗教的なもので
実際にものを持ってきて
奥さんこれ買わなかったらあれやこれやと
あんた約束したでしょ
買うと言って 今度からはもうもうもうとことんもう電話かけてやるぞ
旦那にも言うそうと言っちゃうとね
あ そう どうぞ頑張ってくださいと
まあこちらもそこで警察に弁護士知ってる弁護士もいるんだから
いなくてもいいんですよ
あの相談してみますので
一緒にいかがでしょうか？と出て行きますよ
私にもなんか要らん Eメールいっぱい来るんだから
まあ要するに何かもわからないけども
次から次へと脅し合ったんですよ
で なんかお金払いなさいと
で 最初のメールにあったのは
あなたはなんとかなんとかの会員になりましたと
会員に何やこれと知らない
会員になったことで まあおめでとうございますと
で  2週間以内で 5万かなね
あの入金してくださいと
でないとこのあなたの会員は取り消されますと
はい 同然ということで
何も返事も何もしなかったんですけど
それからまたまだ調べたところでお金払ってないんだと
まだだったらまだお金払ってないんだからね
これからこちらのほうの借金取り
お金を取る人々が来ますから
それどうで別にちょこっとこいつらに返事出そうかね
別に相手は返事受けるぐらいの能力ある人ではないんだから
それぐらいでお金払う人がいるのかと
で まあ終わりましたしね
だから脅しにはあんまり気にしないでください
そういう権利ないんですよ
脅しにはみんな怖いんだからね
人を脅す権利はないんですよ
たとえ品物を買ったっても
3 1ヶ月とか見ないで返す権利がありますからね
気にしないでください
これで質問さん 世間知らずの危険性のね
上の人 1に似ているのですが
ちょっと違う例です 世の中に出た以上
果たさなければいけない責任があったり
いろいろ気を遣ったりする必要があります
それに気づかず無茶な行動をして品目を買ってしまう
この場合も世間知らずと呼ばれます
社会人として身につけなければならない知識をお釈迦様はどのように教えられていますか？という質問です
で 答え 勉強すること 習うことなどは残念ながら否定できません
仏教でも社会人になったら学ぶべきものというのはいろいろありますから
それはもう残念です 学んでください
勉強しないでいいってわけじゃないんです
それはブッダの立場です
何でもかんでも学ぶというふうに言ってないんです
自分に必要なものだけはもう学んでおきなさいと
人は成長する 向上する
進化するもので それを肝に銘じて覚えておいてください
人間というのは完璧じゃないんです
じわじわじわじわと成長するもんですよ
これしっかりと覚えてほしいんです
完璧でないことはそんなに
恥ずかしいことではありませんよ
人間というのは動的で
どんどんどんどん じわじわじわじわと向上するんだから
失敗しても 品目を買っても気にしないで
前向きに進む それだけ
新しい会社に入ったらものすごい品格買ってしまったと
別に気にしないでへっちゃらでいいんです
だって人間というのは向上するもんだからね
向上するんだ 自分がどんどん進化するんだと覚えておけば
そんなにショック受けませんよ
それで終わり それで質問の 4
じゃああんたたち世間を知ってるの？という
でも世間を知っているなんて相対的なものであって
環境やそれぞれの分野によって変わってしまうものだと思います
ある分野でものすごく事情通な人が
別の分野には全然ついていけなかったりすると
それで一応意味わかるでしょ
それに答え これは知識のことですね
引いているのは 知識は日々増えるんですよ
間違った知識はなくなっていくんですね
世の中では知識というのは固定してないんです
今正しいと思うのは もうちょこっと時間経つとあれが間違ったと平気でなるでしょう
人はそれぞれの知識が違う
それから一人一人人の知識も違うでしょうに
そのすべてを学ぶことは無理
不可能 必要ではありません
知識全部学ぶ必要はありませんよ
ある分野でもうものすごい情報
何通でしたっけ？えっ
事情事情通かもしれませんだけど
他の分野で全くダメだと
それでいいんじゃないんですかね
別に 全て知る必要はまるっきりありません
これは不可能 無理 知識が違うから互いに関係を持ってるのです
我々は何で人間関係作ってますかね
この知識違いだからなんですよ
病気にはなったんだけど
自分では治療方法を知らない
知識がないんですよ それでお医者さんにお願いしますと言うでしょうに
それで関係を持ってるでしょう
子供は元気で一人で独立して色々やりたいんだけど
もう力がないんですよ
いろんな漫画本とか買いたいんだけど
お金もないんですよ だからお父さんお母さん
ちょっと 500円ちょうだいと言うでしょうに
あげませんと言っちゃうと
なんかごまかしちゃったりして
お母さんの機嫌を取ったりして
なんとかして 500円取ったりする
それが人間関係でしょうに
だから知識はバラバラっていうことがありがたいことなんですよ
それで天才的なピアノを弾ける人がいる
もうもうもうピアノをぶん殴ることはできるんだけど
全然弾けない人もいる
それで弾けない人はお金を払ってピアノの演奏を聴く
皆様がピアノ通だったらもうむちゃくちゃでしょうね
うるさくて だから知識バラバラっていうことはありがたいことで
全部知ってやろうと思うのはもうとんでもない誤解なんです
知識 経験などを交換することが社会性
人生です そこで我々は知識経験を交換する
ヒマラヤに登ったおじいさんがテレビに出て
どうやって登ったかとか
どんな苦しいことがあったのかとか
みんなで喋る それで私たちもこれを聞いて
自分たちも登ったような気分になる
それで人間関係成り立ってる
そのおじいさんもお金もらうし
私たちもそれで楽しいでしょうに
だから知識バラバラでなきゃ困りますよ
経験バラバラでなきゃ
私は知るものはあなたに
あなたはあなたが知るものは私にという人間関係でしょ
したがって 世間知らずでよかったのです
何でも知るとことが危ないんです
ありえないしね だからこの時点
質問の場合は世間知らずでいいんです
質問まだあります  5番目
普遍的な世間の知識 世間についての真理では
その場の状況に左右されず
知っておけば必ず役に立つ世間についての
知識はあるのでしょうか？と
はあ 難しい質問ですね
では 文章だけ難しいんですけどね
いわゆる真理と言える真理があるのかと
その人を聞いてますよ
必ず役に立つ世間という知識がありますかと
必ず役に立つもの お釈迦様はそういうところをどう説かれるでしょうか
ということ で 答え あります
必ずしも役に立つ どうしても知っておかなくちゃいけない知識はあります
それは十悪と十善です
はっきり言ってもたった 10項目です
20項目ではありませんよ
十善十悪といっても これさえ知っておけば完璧です
あの それについて あの
まあ来月のパティ話題になると思いますけど
巻頭で書きましたので
あの そこまで生きていらっしゃるのであれば
お読みになってください
一応私は生きていなくても
一応書いたんだから  出ることは出ます
しかし いい加減な無責任な社会の誘惑に対応するために
鵜呑みにしないこと 自分で判断すること
理性を保つこともあるのです
これ言わなくてもいいんですよ
2番目はどうしてもあれで物足らないと思うならば
まあ鵜呑みにしない人間になる
理性を保つというぐらい
その能力だけは必要なんです
物事を自分で判断する
相手がデータ提供してもしても
判断は相手の判断に乗ってはいけないんですよ
押し売りに来た人でも
データだけ提供すれば十分です
だから買ってだから買ってこうやらなきゃ損やとかね
言うと それでもう話はもう成り立たないんです
できなくても これ 2番目できなくても
2番目ちょこっと難しいんだからね
十悪をやめるだけで十分です
十悪をやめてみると 見事に人生は変わります
はい まあそんなところかな
また質問がありますね
現代の情報化社会で世間を読めるか
もうテレビのニュースや新聞もどこまで本当のことを伝えているのかわからない世の中です
と これ重大な問題ですよ
世間に目を向けようとしても
どの情報も怪しくて 何が正しいのか判断できないと
情報の社会で どう答えればいいんですかね
その場合は また続きあるみたい
誰かの手によって情報が操作改ざんされている危険もある
佐藤さんの名前も入っています
これを佐藤さんはきなこの前に座ってる人ですけど
メディア何でしたっけ？ メディアリテラシーですね
正確には  何？ メディアリテラシー
これはメディアリテラシー
まあまあ これはメディアリテラシーっていうのは
このまあ日本語に訳すると情報文学ということなんです
ニュース文学なんです
ニュースじゃなくて ただ文学なんです
そう言うとバレますから
みんなわけもわからないカタカナ語を使っています
メディアリテラシーといえばかっこよく聞こえますでしょ
なぜならば リテラシーっていうのは知識人という意味もありますからね
英語でリテラシーといえば
よく学んで よく知識人でという意味もありますよ
だから そういう人々は自分やっている詐欺行為にかっこつけて
メディアリテラシーと書いています
だから日本語訳して  それに対する批判のことを最近はメディアリテラシー
そうですか それにはわかりませんだけど
まあそれは意味は メディアリテラシーという意味の場合は
やっぱり情報文学ということなんですね
それで悪いということはすぐわかります
情報に踊らさ踊らされる危険があるわけです
正しい情報を読み取る力はどうすればつくでしょうか
お釈迦様はどう説かれるでしょうかと
お釈迦様の時代 そんな詐欺師はいなかったんですけどね
メディアとかなんとかなかったんですけど
でも答えの質問されたら答えなくちゃいけないんですよ
情報を操作していると知ってるならば
それほど心配する必要はありませんと
でしょ もうわかってることだから
もう誰一人正しい情報を出さないんだと
操作しているんだと だったら別に心配
まあそこそこほどほどに入手すれば結構です
たとえニュースでも 現代のニュースメディアは情報伝達ではなく
エンターテインメント娯楽です
たとえニュース番組でも
お笑い番組と同じく娯楽なんですよ
今は だから楽しんでやればいいんですよ
別に ああ そうかそうかと
なぜどこかで人を殺したら
ワイドショーでそちらに行って中にも入らないくせに
外で泣きながら喋るんだから
スクリプト同じなんですよ
スタジオの中でも同じスクリプトを読んで
男が一回読んで 女が一回読んで
それから飛行機に乗って
その場所に誰かが行って
そこでまたマイクを持って
また泣きながら同じスクリプト読み上げるんだからね
だからお金の無駄遣いで
まあ食べてるんだからね
情けない仕事で かわいそうですけどもね
かつては尊い仕事でしたかもしれませんだけどね
今は最悪 答えの続き それを理解すれば結構です
このエンターテインメントだと娯楽だと理解しておけば
まあ適当に 例えばたとえ小説であろうとも
舞台であろうとも あれは明らかに嘘でしょ
嘘なんですけど それ知ってるんだから
人生に役に立つものを取れるんですよ
小説読んで馬鹿になるわけないでしょうに
小説を読むといろんな知識が入りますよ
今も私は読んでいる小説では
もうイタリア語やらイタリアの文学やら
もうキリスト教の文学やら
もう人々の考え方やら
むちゃくちゃ勉強になるんですけど
そもそもが小説なんです
作り話なんです だからこの小説
今読んでいる小説を書いた人も
最初にこれこれだけはデータだよと
まあ他はもう作り話だよとちゃんと書いてますからね
そうなくても なんでそう書く羽目になったかというと
ものの見事に本当のことのように書くんですよ
すごい精密にもう合わせて合わせて
だから出てくる場所 人物
全部歴史的で そうしちゃうと
内容も会話もかなり科学的ないろんなものが入ってきて
そうなっちゃうと 私たちはなんかそのまま鵜呑みにしてしまう羽目になるんだから
そこまで操作能力が発展しています
もうフィクション フィクションやとまるっきり気づかないように書くと
それは文学の能力でしょうし
だから前もって注意入れて読むんです
ここまでは本当のことで
ここまでは嘘やと あの皆様の間で人気あったあのダ・ヴィンチコードやらね
あれごちゃ混ぜでしょ？データとフィクションは
で かなり研究してダン brown さんが書いたんですよ
私はあのダ・ヴィンチコードよりはこのエンジェルス
ディーモンズアンドエンジェルスという本がすごくいい作品だと思いますね
えーと 天使と悪魔たちというね
あれもかなりもうなぜ気に入ったかというと
一般人に手に入らないヴァティカンのもう内装の情報ちゃんと取ってもう書いているんです
だから フィクションと事実をうまくつなげる
だからそれが小説であると知ってるんだから
私たちはフィクションはフィクションで
情報は情報できちんと切り離すことができます
そういうわけで 今の現代のニュース
テレビ 新聞の場合でも
すべてフィクションであると
娯楽であると 見てみると二ついいところがありますよ
この人間がどれぐらい文学作家として能力あるのか
どれぐらい頑張って人楽しやってるのかと
それは人の能力でしょう
実際のデータはどれぐらいなのかと
私はいつもその 2つに分けて見るんですよ
この 3時間  1時間番組
ワイドショーでやってる時でも
実際の情報っていうのはほんの 2 3 行しかないんですよ
それには飛行機を飛んでアメリカに行くわ
フランスに行くわ 日本各地に行くわ
いろんな人をインタビューするわ
すべて無駄 まあすべて番組作るんですね
それは作品で だからこのそれを理解しておけば
あの区別能力はよく身につきます
情報を流す側にも受ける側にも問題があるからこのようになったんですよ
だって人間っていうのは情報だけは知ろうとしない怠け者で無知で
でもそれで困ると情報知ってもらわなくてはと
だから情報を伝える側がもう娯楽に入っちゃったんです
娯楽なら聞く 読むニュースなら嫌やと
そうなっちゃったんだから
ニュースも娯楽にしちゃったんです
だから悪いのはお互い様なんですよ
マスメディアも一般の方々もお互い様
もう裁かなくちゃいけないんです
ブッダの立場は 自分に役に立つこと
良い人間になるために必要情報のみを入れることです
娯楽に注意することです
ブッダいうのは 自分の役に立つことになったらそれだけで十分だからね
いらんものはカットしなさいと
人格向上するものは入れてくださいと
娯楽ばっかしには追っていくなよと
小説読んでも 自分の人格に役に立つようなところだけ
そういう小説だけ選んで読めばいいんです
小説数とかね もう映画とかならなくてもいいんです
役に立つ すごい気に入る
いい映画だったらそれを見る
その小説が出たらそれを読むというぐらいで管理した方がいいんです
それはブッダの立場から言えば答えなんです
さあ これで終了だと思います
質問 無駄な情報を遮断する
お釈迦様から言えばね
で はい 終了です  はい